A natural lifespan is probably between
$100,
120 years.
That seems to be about what
people can handle.
Um,
it's true that in the United States and
other established market economy,
countries,
wealthy countries,
we spend a tremendous amount of money at
the end of life.
Now I'm one of these people that thinks
that everybody's life is of equal value.
The life of an 85 year old is just as
precious as a 12 year old and they are
entitled to as many efforts to save
their life as a younger person.
And I don't think one can say that,
well,
you know,
a 12 year old or a 20 year old because
they have so much more potential years
ahead of them.
Um,
is more valuable as a human being than
someone who's 85.
I'm on the other hand,
I think we have to be cognizant that
when we spend money for healthcare,
it should be for healthcare.
Um,
sometimes we spend money just prolonging
the dying process.
And that's clearly,
I think,
the wrong thing to do,
not just from a financial point of view,
but from a human point of view,
if all we're doing is,
is increasing someone's suffering and
not really doing anything that can
meaningfully prolong their life in a way
that has value to them,
then I think we shouldn't do that.
But it sort of raises a larger issue.
Your question about how we can make the
population generally healthier,
as everyone knows,
it's been widely reported.
You know,
we spend more money on healthcare in
United States,
in any other country,
but we don't seem to be the healthiest
people on Earth.
We don't live longer than other people.
In fact,
we live less long than people in many
countries.
Um,
infant mortality in the United States is
higher than it is in many countries who
spend less money on healthcare than we
do.
So.
So I think we could be getting more out
of the money we spend on healthcare.
And in one of the ways to do that is to
think about public health approaches to
improving the health
of the population of.
I like to point out that frankly,
the person who's done more for the
health of New Yorkers in the last
several years than,
than anyone is the mayor.
Um,
and that's because he's really made it
so difficult to smoke cigarettes in New
York.
It's very expensive and you can't do it
in public m and a smoking rates have
dropped quite a bit in New York.
You know,
that's a good example of a public health
approach to a problem.
All sorts of things affect health,
not just medicine,
you know,
legal things,
economic things,
cultural things,
social things.
All these things address health impact.
And,
and,
uh,
I think if we realize that we get a lot
more out of the money we spend on
healthcare.